we got a question from Georgia in
Montreal or was it Montreal in Georgia I
had it right the first time
that was after listening to the
nostalgia episode I took a long hard
look at the hoard of baby clothes and
other baby like baby items that no
longer fit or add value to my son's life
but that I was holding on to for a
possible future child this process
forced me to really set my intentions
and priorities for the next few years
and it shifted my perspective in many
ways to be honest though I do sometimes
have feelings of loss or other difficult
emotions when having some decisions and
whenever I let go of things even though
it can feel good I sometimes feel this
loss so how do you deal with the or
tolerate the emotional journey that
minimalism can take you on even when
there's joy with let's say for example
keeping just a few select items that
trigger two happy feelings how do you
deal with the ambivalent feelings when
then it goes other stuff alright so the
word ambivalent here I would use a
different word so I'm ambivalent about
ambivalence right if you're ambivalent
torn item I tend to let it go because if
it's if I'm ambivalent it's like why do
I want to hold on to this thing right
yeah just to be clear ambivalence for me
it means like basically having not
feeling not a feeling one way or the
other a feeling that's not one way or
the other it is in between you know
either pain or pleasure it's it's
nothing so much I think maybe what
George is saying is ambivalence are
worse like if you feel ambivalence or
you feel negative feeling which clearly
she does with some of these she has
these hoards of baby clothes and other
baby items that she's talking about and
she's holding on to them just in case
she has another kid in the future right
she's not really sure it's not like
she's pregnant right now and she knows
there's another kid at least that wasn't
clear from from her message so so she
also mentioned that triggers and she has
these these holding onto some items that
trigger these positive memories and I
just wanna say yes congratulations
because the memories aren't in the
things the memories are are in us and
sometimes though those things can
trigger the memories that are inside us
so by holding on to a few items having
fewer things
we can actually use those to trigger
those good feelings in us
however by watering it down with tens of
thousands of old baby items just sitting
around in boxes and bins those aren't
really triggers for old memories those
are just weights that are holding you
back yeah something like which they were
just in case items for her yeah rather
than just for when right so no I mean
sit so that to me that is you know
earlier when I talked about how this
podcast could be called boundaries like
for someone like Georgia she has to be
able to create these boundaries like so
when it comes to just in case of course
we have the 20 20 just in case for we've
got the 90 90 rule there are different
rules that you and I have set up for
ourselves yes to help us not hold on to
these things so with Georgia I mean the
first thing I thought of was well she
does not you know she's not sure she's
gonna have a kid or not so what are the
rules that she has for herself in
keeping these baby clothes yeah so you
know having the rule of just throwing
them out or just donating them I should
say um you know that's I guess that's
okay that doesn't seem like it doesn't
seem very deliberate to me if she's
still wonder you know questioning
whether or not she's gonna have a kid in
the next year so yeah and then holding
on to everything just in case that also
doesn't seem like the best solution
there's something in the middle there
and really like Georgia's gonna have to
figure out what that middle is for her
yeah and so asking yourself what is your
outcome here because if you do plan to
have another kid then the question is
win yes so if you're saying I'm gonna
have a kid in two years okay great then
then the next question is what are the
items that you want to hold on to for
that kid because clearly you don't want
to hold on to all of these things most
likely you've learned some lessons from
the first kid you always do right now
I've learned a whole lot of lessons from
having Ellis you just turned five
recently we took her down to Disneyland
posted that crazy picture of her on the
on the so good on stories Oh Mike it was
just good I had to redownload Instagram
to post it and it was just this you know
zoom in zoom it you can actually find on
my Instagram stories right now put it on
just still on there well they you know
what are those things called did I don't
yeah
the at the top the the Instagram stories
tabs you have these different tabs the
moments moments they're called oh so
it's like Center them yeah it's under
the
family did not even know that existed
yeah it's under the family moment on my
my Instagram stories I'm just at Joshua
fields Melbourne if you want to see the
most so good it's the best family
picture we've ever taken and it is pure
it's remember a Leoville Balsas term joy
fear yeah that is she personified the
expression of joy fear especially when
you zoom in our face it was the
precipice of total terror and also utter
and complete joy it's the same moment
when I saw that picture when we came off
the ride I was like oh my god like
Ella's she's never gonna trust us again
haha
but like because she looks so scared
right but dude she was like can we ride
that again
yeah I guess we know that line is two
hours long I don't care how it's riding
together yeah she loved it was like the
it was no Splash Mountain log flume ride
and yeah it was just scary enough that
she loved it anyway I've learned a whole
lot of lessons through my five years
with her Wow when I met Beck's Ella was
was one so three and a half years with
her and I've learned a lot of lessons so
if we ever had another kid in the future
which we likely won't but if we had a
second kid there were certainly things I
learned from that from this crash test
dummy named Ella that we we all carry
forward right no I and that the truth is
like I learned really Ella wasn't the
crash test dummy I was I was the crash
test dummy for parenting right like I'm
learning I'm learning how to become a
better parents one of the hardest things
I've ever done it's probably the hardest
thing I've ever done and especially for
me with with my personality and so I've
learned a lot and I know that Kara if I
had a second kid carry that forward
there are some things literal things
physical things I'd get rid of and also
at different experiences I bring in more
of and bring in less and so what are the
things you're gonna want to and then of
course if two years from now you're like
okay I've decided I'm not going to get
pregnant then you give yourself full
permission there's a drop-dead date on
on these items there's an expiration
date for these items right and you want
to give yourself permission to let go
though so maybe that said having the
9090 rule it's the one-year rule and if
you're not pregnant in a year then you
decide you know I'm not getting value
from these things anymore
someone else could get value from them
so I better let them go so someone else
can and that Ryan goes back to your
point differentiating the just in case
items which don't hold on to them if
they're just in case hold on to them if
they're just for win and you can
honestly say you know when you're going
to use them right now George is
somewhere right in between and so you
need to set up a rule for yourself that
says at this point they're no longer
just for one item this is when they
become just in case and when it's just
in case item I'm getting it the hell out
of here yeah well it's funny because
like when it comes to just in case items
there's always going to be a reason to
hold on it I mean hoarders like the true
sense of the word hoarder you walk into
someone's home you can't see their floor
they've got a newspaper sect everywhere
they are holding on to those newspapers
just in case yes now most people they're
not gonna have stacks and newspapers
right they're gonna let them go for one
reason to the other I would encourage
you know people to look at that reason
and see if they can apply to other areas
of their life what a great point and see
if it makes sense but you know listening
to George George's question I two things
came to mind and I'm not trying to make
this black or white but I feel like one
or two things are happening here with
Georgia either a she is holding on to
stuff just in case or maybe when she
maybe she got she let it go I couldn't
really tell by the question that she let
it go or was no I okay so let's let's
say she does let it go and she
experiences regret a year from now and
she's like oh man like I really really
should not have let that stuff go and
here are the reasons why then that's
okay like it's again there is no perfect
minimalist you might get rid of
something that you wish you would have
hung on to but learn from that lesson
don't don't continue to you know just
throw everything away to only experience
that same regret every single time III
can't I wish I had a sexy answer when
people are like hey guys what's one
thing you got rid of that you really
feel a lot of regret with and like I
don't have a sexy answer for that and at
but I'm sure there are people out there
who have went down this road and they do
feel regret of getting rid of something
like really look at that regret and ask
like how could have I avoided that and
here's why I needed to avoid that the
other the other thing that I think might
be going on
is giorgia might just have you know
these tents you might have had these
tendencies to hold on to stuff from the
beginning of life I mean III have had
mentoring students who they're like you
know I got rid of this one thing and its
really really driving me crazy I don't
know why it's driving me crazy but it's
really weighs on me and when I think
about it you know I'm a little upset
that I let it go and in a lot of the
times I'll take you know kind of deep
into that and what I find out is that
these are feelings that they've had ever
since they were a kid they were you know
collected rocks I collected sticks that
you know then they got really sick POW
and they've felt bad about letting it go
my point is is that there are these
emotions that some that we are born with
sometimes that emotionally makes sense
because we feel them right but logically
they don't make sense yeah and and I
think that that is a very important
thing to to recognize essentially like I
think about my my my
I'm very prone to getting angry really
easily uh-huh and I used to think that I
was justified and get especially my
relationships soon as I get offended as
soon as I get jealous as soon as I get
insecure and then I would you know I get
angry and I would voice my my angry
feeling and I felt completely justified
in doing that well once I realized that
that me acting on that is actually
ruining relationships I had to really
question whether or not those emotions
whether they logically made sense for me
to have now you could be right or you
can be in love you can't be both right
exactly man so so you know what when I
look at like me getting angry really
easily I know that when I have this
anger this feeling of you know anger
shoot through me I've got to be able to
look at that and say okay Ryan I know
you feel this way yeah
but but really like how would how would
the best version of yourself
react in this situation so I have tools
to help calm me down whether it's you
know taking the deep breath or a couple
deep breaths or whether it's like
rephrasing the way something was a
position to me whatever it might be I
have different tools to help me deal
with this emotion what I'm getting at is
is that it's important for
to recognize that this emotion that I
have is not valid it is not adding any
value it is you know by and large it's
not adding any value so I'm just trying
to relate here with Georgia where she's
got to be able to look at this feeling
that that this hoarding feeling that she
has and she's got it look at that and
say is this valid if it isn't then she
has to find ways to kind of tell that
that that hoarding mentality or that you
know just in case mentality to to kind
of sit on the back burner yes I
understand that I feel that way but
logically I'm not gonna sit here and you
know have a storage storage locker full
of baby clothes I have to find the
in-between and she might get rid of the
baby clothes and she still might feel a
little bit of a loss she so might feel a
little bit of regret but to me what
really is important is whether or not
that regret is valid or not yes yeah
well and so so you're bringing up a
couple things that I want to talk about
one is I don't think the the fear of
potential regret so that if you the fear
of potential regret is not a good reason
to not let go absolutely and because one
you don't know whether or not if that's
the only reason you're holding on to
something is because you might regret it
in some hypothetical future then it's
probably not adding value to your life
and it's not going to and is likely not
going to add value to your life right
now you're also talking about emotions
and feelings and I've always equated
those two as being synonymous but I went
to a Sam Harris event recently man well
he was there with an author Antonio
D'Agostino I believe anyway I'm messing
with the name he has a new book out that
delineates the the the the difference
between emotion and feeling a feeling is
something that we experience internally
an emotion is something that we react on
either either consciously or
unconsciously an emotion the the feeling
could be fear the emotion is that we the
heart the the heart starts beating
quickly and we start getting the sweaty
palms that interesting and so
there is a differentiation between the
two and so where she might be feeling it
are these emotions because it's making
her feel a particular way the the the
sense of urgency of I can't let go
because I'm gonna need this so I'm gonna
hold on because otherwise like I feel
this like anxious feel emotion anxiety
can be an emotion and the feeling is
like you said it may or may not be
justified right there isn't a real fear
here of letting go because the worst
thing that can happen if you let go of
these baby clothes the worst thing that
can happen is someone else is going to
get some value from them and you might
have to buy some used baby clothes in
the future
you